this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by men's wearhouse
you're only going to get that joke if
you're watching this on youtube and this
is an episode you definitely want to
watch on youtube this episode is brought
to you by nobody because advertisements
suck
minimalists
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists today is the day
ryan we have a gift for everyone so
before we even get into the intro
let's reveal the gift we've been working
on this for many many
months yeah and now we are ready to
finally reveal our brand new studio
we have a gift for you let's unwrap it
if you're watching this on youtube
let's do it
oh welcome to the minimalist brand new
podcast studio have you ever decluttered
a space but then felt compelled to fill
it with new things
oh man
that can be dangerous
once we've excised our excess the last
thing we want to do is re-clutter our
lives with new possessions new burdens
new obligations today we're going to
talk about how to avoid
re-cluttering our lives with excess
ryan i thought this was the perfect
episode to do this we've been waiting to
do this recluttering episode right
because we moved into this new studio
space we have a brand new studio
audience here by the way
[Laughter]
uh yeah we have um alabama emma the
immigrant and danny unknown is around
here somewhere
hiding behind the cameras of course
jordan no more podcast sean are all here
and what's funny is we have some people
who have been moving to los angeles we
moved to this new studio
and the spaces we move into they tend to
be empty yeah and so the first thing we
want to do is what reclutter it yeah
fill it with stuff that's right oh i am
empty if this space is empty
we've been very careful and it's taken
way longer than what we initially
thought we were like hey maybe we'll get
like two episodes with that wrapping
paper behind us
and it was fine it worked well for a
season yeah but we knew we were going
somewhere else with it so we're we're
roughly 70 of the way there we've got
this beautiful artwork here by beulah
we're going to talk more about beulah
anne a little bit later she is the
wonderful artist also interior designer
behind our new studio space we'll talk
more about her also shout out to evan
cox who does all of our lighting he came
in here and has made things look
beautiful we still have quite a bit to
do with our lighting yeah that's all
right yeah
evans is savant man oh my god yeah he's
a total genius he sees things with
lighting yeah that yeah it's almost like
he's uh he has you know the when people
have synesthesia
they can play music and they see colors
yeah he has that with lighting somehow
somehow yeah and i just remember the
first time he was in here uh he did some
things with the lighting
and it didn't look any different to me
and then jordan showed me on the camera
side by side i was like oh my god i had
no idea josh could look that handsome
well evan thank you for making us look
about 36 percent more handsome on camera
it's all camera tricks by the way we
have some new camera equipment we're
upgrading to 4k real soon as well for
youtube what we're trying to do is we've
have a message here that we've been
talking about for 10 or 11 years we've
refined that message and we want to make
it look beautiful as our friend irwin
mcmanus says beauty is essential and we
want to bring that forward in fact we're
often inspired by some of the art that
they've done over at mosaic and seeing
the art that they've put forward in in
all of their creations and how can we
also make what we're doing look
beautiful one last person to shout out
big thanks to tim who you have not met
you're out of town last week from woe of
arts he's the guy who hung all of this
artwork and made this space look like a
beautiful art gallery yeah he did a
great job is that is that the guy that
you were talking about danny oh awesome
yeah he's he's amazing and a really
talented artist really understands art
history
just a beautiful soul beautiful person
and uh so we're working with an amazing
team here to make beauty
of that we're going to bring beauty to
the forefront of everything that we are
doing this year and into the future but
we got to be careful because beauty is
not the same thing as well let's fill
the space in fact we've done the
opposite we've been very deliberate
about not
overflowing this space with new things
oh it's so easy you come in here
especially when we first walked in here
it was like an echo chamber
remember the first time we came in here
yeah it was crazy man yeah
yeah so uh mike he brought in the sound
panels mike over at la sound panels and
and uh by the way these are we're just
shouting people out there's no
sponsorships here or anything like that
we pay full price for all of these
people to to help us out but what's
beautiful is working together with this
team what we're trying to do is well it
was it's a beautiful message that has
worked really well for audio but how can
we pull this forward into a visual
representation and you see that in our
homes as well that's by the way that's
why we're wearing these suits right now
it's a celebration
how long do you think it'll take before
i spill coffee on my shirt
i tried to get ryan to wear a tuxedo
t-shirt today
oh man i almost did i almost did
everyone thought it was a good idea but
i think ryan was just a little bashful
oh i just wanted to give uh beulah and
tim
and uh uh
evan and everyone else the respect that
they deserve and i thought you know i
don't i don't put on a tie often yeah
but i'll do it for their work okay yeah
yeah no it's it's a beautiful a
beautiful day that we finally get to
unveil this and you'll see over the
coming weeks and months we still have a
whole lot more in store for you you can
listen to the audio version keep
listening to the audio i'm not trying to
say go do something different what we
want to do is bring this beauty forward
bring some art into everything that we
do we'll talk more about beulah and her
artwork a little bit later on this
minimal episode ryan i want to talk to
you about recluttering
and on the maximal episode this week
we're going to talk about 25 boundaries
that prevent
a cluttered life
now that can be cluttered with things
but also clutter with relationship
clutter career clutter
emotional clutter that's a big one for
me emotional clutter so i want to talk
to you about that on the maximal episode
also on patreon this week i want to talk
to you more about voting we had a
conversation last week about voting and
i had some additional insights but
really some additional questions that i
want to talk to you about as well is
voting actually the problem
i don't know uh let's see yes and no oh
okay well let's talk about it that's how
you look at it yeah also recent maximal
episodes over on patreon we did an
episode called the opposite of hoarding
and we did one called the digital
declutter challenge you can check those
out patreon.com
the minimalist but let's get into this
episode ryan we have a facebook question
from desiree
how do we address re-cluttering with
loved ones and roommates who seem to see
our clean spaces as places to dump their
stuff that doesn't have a home yeah i
think that's
what's fascinating about this i think
we're all this way to some extent as i
mentioned earlier you walk into an empty
room or i know
danny's moving into a new place right
now i just saw pictures of his new
apartment it's beautiful it's a small
apartment and what he's realized like oh
i have
too much stuff for this space i had too
much stuff for my life maybe but it's
especially obvious when i move into this
new space but whenever we move into a
new space what do we feel oh i have to
have the things that i'm supposed to
have i have to have a couch i have to
have a bed i have to have a dining room
table i have to have a blender i have to
have a george foreman grill and all of a
sudden the list goes on and on and on
and a lot of this these are
non-essentials and the question about a
non-essential is
will it add value to my life
there's nothing wrong with having
non-essentials but many of these things
are actually going to get in the way and
i think that's where desiree is right
now other people's stuff
is getting in your way yeah and i know
maybe it's driving you crazy a little
bit mm-hmm
dude the counter is like my biggest um
put everything there like
i get like we'll get the counter like
nice and clear the kitchen counter
because it's like nice and wide
and all that does is like attract
everything
that i don't have like an exact place
for but what's really cool is like
mariah and i
we uh try to keep it as clutter free as
possible some days we do better than
others but we're constantly working
together towards the same thing so like
we
we know what we want we know our
preferences uh we have conversations
about it and
it's usually her getting on me about
stuff but sometimes you know like her
art stuff will be out and i'm like oh
hey do you mind you know taking care of
this or sometimes i'll take care of
before yeah but yeah with with loved
ones it might be a little easier with
roommates
like i had that roommate from
hades
[Music]
back in ohio yeah yeah and like there
was nothing i could do
to like help him
or to yeah to make him see
that he needed to take care of our
personal space right i've eventually
moved out which maybe that's not what
you know does uh yeah desiree needs to
do here is move out maybe now you could
certainly have a conversation at first
but you know i had a lot of
conversations with him and uh it just
ended up not working out i have some
insights from anthony demello that i
think might help desiree this is from
his book rediscovering life
and this section this is from page 67.
nothing in this world upsets you
get your get your soul ready for a shock
here it comes i say it just like it is
i'm going to lob the bomb right into
your midst listen to this
nothing in reality nothing in life
nothing in the world upset you
nothing has the power to upset you did
anyone ever tell you that
all upset exists in you
not in reality
you can underline the word all
all of it all of it all of it all upset
is in you
not in life
not in reality not in the world
it's in you
just understanding this has changed the
lives of people 180 degrees just
understanding this and no more
reality is not upsetting reality is not
problematic
and if there were no human mind
there would be no problems all problems
exist
in the human mind all problems are
created by the mind somebody said to me
in denver last summer wouldn't there be
some problems that existed in reality
and not in me i said to him
if we take you out of there where's the
problem
no problem
now to me
this truth is so simple a seven-year-old
child could understand it but i've met
people who are doctors and all sorts of
other things and they never understood
it
never understood it
they just took it for granted that
problems exist in the world problems
exist
by problem i mean something that upsets
you okay i repeat that by problem i mean
something that upsets you people think
the problem exists in the world
they think that exists in other people
they think it exists in life
no no no
it's in them
simple as that
nothing has the power
to upset you um
it's like freeing in a way it's like uh
i don't know it just helps you look at
any time you get pissed off like you can
really ask yourself like
did this person upset me or have have
they just uh said something that you
know where anger arises in me right and
i don't know why but with all this like
the mystic stuff i always go to
because
like
anthony tamello is speaking in an
absolute there with
there are no one can upset you
so with any absolute just like people do
with what we talk about with minimalism
it's like i look for like the
uh oh what's the exception to the rule
and what i'm starting to be more and
more comfortable with is that that's
life man there's exceptions to all rules
there might be yeah but i think what
he's saying there is the problem will
always exist in you because if you
didn't exist that problem wouldn't exist
in the same way the worry the upset
the
the experience that you're having and so
desiree the reason i bring this up is
not to say well the problem's all yours
deal with it
i'm saying if we realize that then we're
not reacting to this emotionally
and we can react from it
we can react to it in a way where we
actually understand the problem is it
really a problem
and if so we don't have to emotionally
react because that's where a lot of
these questions stem from you you wait
to the point at which you are
exacerbated by the problem because when
it was just gnawing at you a little bit
oh they keep putting their keys on the
counter and it's frustrating you don't
say anything but then there's the pile
of mail there and then there's all the
flat surfaces start to have different
things on them there's pizza boxes and
beer cans and soda bottles and all this
stuff
that's all over the house and now you've
reached the boiling point yeah and
you've been upset the entire time
realizing that oh that upset arises in
me why because i have a particular
desire i have particular expectation i
have an attachment to a clean house and
okay
understanding that
is
i think is the antidote to being upset
by this because as soon as you're not
upset by it now you can talk to the
people and say hey i have certain
preferences i also understand that you
have certain preferences
and let's find out where those
preferences can converge now it may be
that you have a roommate who is awful
relative to your preferences doesn't fit
with your preferences that's where you
were ryan yeah your roommate we'll call
him jeff jeff was not able
to
meet your desired preferences right
and
we can either say well it's all his
fault i can blame him
but a real sign of maturity is to not
blame anyone for anything realize like
oh
if i remove myself from this situation
then i've removed the problem from my
interior life as well yeah it's almost
like
desiree can look at this as uh
i don't know if she's upset with it if
if
if uh discontent or whatever it is
arises in her
then she has the choice to do something
about it
and it's it's not in a way it's almost
not her roommate's responsibility to not
make her upset if that makes sense so
let me give you an example let's say um
you know i was wearing a polka dot shirt
yes and you were like dude that really
bothers me you wearing a polka dot shirt
it would to be fair right it would
i'd be really upset right now yeah so
so yeah the question is is like do i
want to
wear a shirt based upon your preferences
or can i just look at you and be like oh
i'm i'm sorry you feel that way right
and just continue wearing my polka dot
shirt i mean it's the same thing with
desiring a roommate she's asking her
roommate hey can you please help me with
these preferences yeah um
but it's you know it's it's not
i don't know i don't want to throw it
all on the roommate here the the other
thing i'm trying to get out too is
desiree
i mean you might have to
maybe tidy up a little bit or doing do
something you know for your roommate to
a show them that you are
trying your best to like live within
your preferences
and uh yeah i mean that's that's a
little bit of a contribution in a way
too i mean i know that like she doesn't
want to pick up dirty
clothes on the floor and stuff like that
i mean sure there certainly are limits
but but these are all things to consider
yeah and i think there are limits but
you get to define what those limits are
and if it's going to make if you feel at
this point in time it's best that you
have roommates because it's the most
affordable solution for you
fine but understand there are additional
costs involved with that if you have
certain expectations if you had the same
exact expectations as your roommates no
problem would arise within you
the difference right now is the
difference in expectations and your
difference in standards you you have a
standard for you
and then applying that standard to
someone else is creating an expectation
for them
do they even know what your expectation
is it's a great place to start and so if
they don't you might want to just sit
down with them and say hey i have
certain standards would you be willing
to help me meet some of those standards
and help me understand how i can meet
your standards at the same time yeah and
the best way really to get people to
help you out or you know contribute to
your life as you help them them out you
contribute to their life like that's
really going to spark that desire in
your roommate now ryan would you be
upset if i take this jacket off because
i'm starting to sweat
not at all all right well we've got a
voicemail question here from hannah in
hartford connecticut i'm currently on
the journey to becoming zero waste which
means that i've been trying to put more
value into the items i own
i've heard you say that if your house
burnt down it wouldn't be a big deal
because
nothing in your home
is is that important to you i guess my
question is
how do i balance putting value back into
my items or the things that i own
and and not letting these possessions
control my life it seems to me hannah
you're asking how can you jump in the
swimming pool and not get wet um
yeah yeah because here's the thing let's
use a different word than value let's
just say attachment i want more
attachment to my items right because
what you're saying is or maybe even
meaning i want to impart more meaning
ascribe more meaning
onto my items well of course they're
going to be more difficult to let go of
right now you can let go of attachment
and not let go of an item and that's
ultimately what i'm talking about she
she misquoted us a little bit by saying
hey if my house burnt down i'd be okay
because nothing's important to me no no
i have plenty all of my things are
important to me
i don't have an attachment to those
things
i don't treat them as disposable
and i think that's the difference she's
mistaking oh all of my things are just
disposable that was the case well i
would just i wouldn't have this glass
right here i would just have a plastic
cup and
and dispose of it and same with the
coffee cup i would just dispose of that
every time and i don't treat things as
though they're disposable
but i understand that those things don't
increase my joy happiness
they have
no value other than the value i assigned
to them and so hannah what you want to
do is you're asking how do i assign more
value to these things and also
reduce my attachment the thing i'm going
to ask about my possessions is
does it add value to my life
not that it has value
but it adds value to my living my
experience of life yeah no i totally
agree man i mean she wants to yeah make
things more precious but not have the
attachment and i don't think that's
necessarily possible i will say
you know when i think about all of the
things that i have
and the attachment i don't have to them
it's really because
i'm trying to sound cliche but like i
really love myself like i really like
who i am i feel complete
and there are other things in my life
that augment my life uh not just things
but relationships as well
and you know that is maybe a better
quality question uh for hannah here is
how can you
how can you fall in love with yourself a
little bit more or how can you feel more
complete
i i will give you a hint it has nothing
to do with your possessions your
material possessions so that's why you
know i think about sentimental stuff i
have i think about expensive stuff that
i had whatever it is it could burn up
and yeah i mean there would be a piece
of me where i'd be like oh man like i
had that stein for you know 20 years and
it was a gift for my grandma and there's
a story attached to it sure but
ultimately
uh i'm going to look at you know well
mariah survived the cat survived and i
survived so you know that's that's
really what's important those are the
true attachments that that i have right
right and we can we can create an
attachment to anything and quite often
we
create attachments to everything hence
hoarding how we're all level one
hoarders to some extent or level two
many of us you can go back to listen to
our hoarding episode about that and ryan
and i identified like oh wow like
especially in our previous lives before
minimalism we had many of the tendencies
of level two hoarders and what does that
mean it just means we picked up a lot of
attachments along the way
now i want you to realize something
hannah that's not
someone else's fault
it's not your fault either
you've been programmed to be attached to
all of these
things through commercials through peer
pressure through your society and
culture
through
friends family whoever it might be
they've had certain cultural
conditioning that they've passed on to
you
and you've picked up a bunch of
attachments along the way well how do
you let go of something letting go is
not something you do it's something you
stop doing so you don't have to let go
of the item
but to let go of the attachment you
simply have to understand
that you no longer want to cling to it
you can find these things useful
we talk about our 16 rules for living
with less and if you want to check them
out it's
theminimalists.comrulebook you can
download it for free
and it's just a
ebook that you can download and check
out these 16 rules for living with less
but a few of them come to mind and they
really helped me with my own attachment
to stuff
the spontaneous combustion rule was the
big one so not your whole house burning
down but let's take a look at one item
pick up that toaster
what would happen if it spontaneously
combusted
would you feel no no that's not hurting
the environment it just combusted it's
gone let's just say it's gone right
would you feel relieved
well if you don't eat any toast yeah
probably it's just sitting there taking
up space right
or would you replace it and if you said
yeah i definitely would want to replace
this toaster great it adds value to your
life but if you feel as though i need
this toaster to be complete just saying
that sentence out loud will make you
realize how absurd that attachment
actually is yeah and i'd love to give
you a couple tickets to
our boston event it's a closest event to
you we're going to 20 cities throughout
north america we're going to be in
boston and new york and dc pretty soon
we're going to texas
in about a week or so we're going to be
in san antonio and houston and dallas
and 20 cities total west coast east
coast midwest will be up in canada as
well you can find all the cities at the
minimalists.com
tour we're definitely coming to a city
near you and uh hannah we can continue
this conversation there in boston we'll
send you two tickets ryan what time is
it you know what time it is it's time
for our lightning round where we answer
your text messages you can text your
questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed you can also
text an emoji to that address i'm
rolling up my sleeves here it's getting
really warm
in the podcast studio
you can text an emoji to that phone
number as well let us know the most
recent thing you got rid of but since
we're talking about recluttering today
before we get to holly's question ryan i
wanted to say something about
re-cluttering the best way to de-clutter
is to avoid bringing the thing home in
the first place
you could tweet that podcast sean i
think quite often the reason we get so
burdened by our stuff by our obligations
by people by ourselves by our
expectations we get burdened because
they pile up over time one thing isn't a
burden for us ah it's just one
thing
that i brought home but we do that 300
000 times and all of a sudden several
decades later we're wondering okay wow
what am i
what am i going to do with all this
this stuff i've been talking to a lot of
people on clubhouse recently i've been
doing these live events on clubhouse
reading from our new book love people
use things and then just answering some
questions around it and it's amazing how
many people are dealing with moving
right now and moved during the pandemic
and when they're moving to these new
spaces they're always telling me the
same thing
i wish i would have done ryan's packing
party before i moved oh yeah because now
i dragged all of these things with me
and i'm re-cluttering my new home with
things i don't even enjoy
but i feel obligated why
why do i feel obligated well it's
because someone said i should have a
couch or i should have a microwave or i
should have a spare bedroom or i should
have a walk-in closet or i should have
clothes that are trendy right i should
own a suit yeah wait i didn't even think
you owned a suit this is i don't i just
owned the tie in the shirt
that's right he's not wearing pants if
you're watching go to the wide shot
you know what man uh it's so easy for us
to become attached man it's like
it is just like there's something in our
dna i don't know what it is but i don't
think it is i don't think it's in the
dna
but i think you're spot on
we're we're steeped in it since birth
basically well we get fooled by it
really easily yeah yeah yeah so you
think it's a
uh
nurture over nature
i think the majority of so we go back
and look at hunter gatherers like
especially pre-haza folks
with respect to
those three things that they really
value i think it's paul gray has a book
about this
and
especially with respect to just kids and
and you're raising kids in a more
natural way the three things that they
value is one is autonomy
two is uh like freedom from
possession or stuff so they they
actually have like they value
non-attachment is the way that you and i
would describe it they don't have
language around it because they don't
have attachment
so if you don't have the thing you don't
have the word for the thing that's why
we're like with schadenfreud like we
have to borrow words from other
languages sometimes or to describe the
thing even though we have the most most
extensive language of all languages
right we start to borrow words from
other cultures yeah i think there's
something sean i don't know if you know
the exact number podcast sean might know
this at 220 240 000 words in the english
language it's an obscene number of words
and i've memorized several dozen of them
if i read the dictionary have i
technically read every book ever written
if you're watching this on youtube
that's my head exploding
um
yes yes you have yeah and you've
you've downloaded all the wisdom as well
right exactly yeah it's funny thing we
think about wisdom is we we think about
experience but wisdom really is seeing
things for how they are the same way we
use all these words to to mean
essentially the same thing yeah i was
having this conversation with uh chris
kelly he has a podcast called nourish
balance thrive he's been on our podcast
before and
yeah i'm talking about attachment and
how he's like well we need attachment
and i'm like okay you say whatever you
want it's all the same thing to me it's
attachment desire yearning
lust
you could clinging call it whatever you
want what is the essence of what you're
talking about if you're talking about
little babies are attached to their
mothers out of biological necessity of
course they are right the problem is we
still have 40 year old men who feel like
they need to breastfeed
right and
and because we we continue we just pick
up different things to become attached
to sure and so yes is there a biological
imperative for attachment yes for babies
and their mothers no no doubt about that
yeah with respect to relationships or
especially things
you look at pre-civilized people and
even like like personal property was
like they weren't against it necessarily
they just didn't understand it at all
well you know it's interesting like they
were
they're attached to community they're
attached to
their their their friends their
relatives like that that tribe or and i
would even call it a tribe uh because
you know we're talking pre
you know pre-human or you know
pre-modern human civilization right so
i they truly were loving people and
using things
yes because that's what mattered the
most of them it was it was their
community yes and uh can you call that
an attachment maybe but you know i think
any of these things that we talk about
attachment
hope whatever it is like these are
these are tools
that
i what i'm starting to understand the
less i use them
the less suffering i have how bingo
however um there are some times that
i'll pull out these tools but i'll tell
you one of those tools is the power of
letting go
and that is where uh yeah actually
hannah or desiree it's like
focus on or
maybe learn how to appreciate the
ability to let go
and see it as a superpower yes because
that is really where i started to foster
the whole attitude of of being willing
to walk away from anything yeah that
willingness to walk away
is freedom and if you ve not saying you
should value freedom right many of us
don't we've imprisoned ourselves with
white picket fences
and we we tie ourselves we attach
ourselves to a job so we can pay for the
car
that gets us to the job
and it's really a strange equation right
you and i did it and when the first car
doesn't work maybe it's the the second
car the upgrade the the limited edition
trim package the bigger house and all of
a sudden we've tethered ourselves
attached ourselves it's the reason i
hate the word attachment is it conjures
up images of positivity oh i'm attached
to the people i love okay well let's
start to use words that might help you
better understand your relationship to
stuff tether
clinging
yearning
suffering
these are words that help me better
understand
my former relationship with things i was
suffering not because of the things the
problem is never the things right the
problem is never the things the problem
is always our attachment to things now
ryan during the lightning round
what we do is we do our best to answer
questions for the short shareable lesson
140 character response we put the text
to these minimal maxims in the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like and now you can find all of our
minimal maxims in one place thanks to
our good friends social jess
they're at minimalmaxims.com all right
we got a question from holly
how do i figure out my why
for
recluttering oh okay so
why okay so maybe let me rephrase the
question a bit because i like the
question if i'm interpreting it
correctly
i've moved into a new space
why do i feel so compelled to
complete it to finish it to clutter it
to fill it whatever word you want to use
there right the essence of it's all the
same right well the why is always the
same as well is because i feel some sort
of emptiness
in
me
if i'm recluttering now if i'm filling
the space with things that add value to
my life then i'm asking different
questions the question like here we're
here in this beautiful space
and
when we first came here it was
complete already
in a way we incomplete the space by
bringing people and sounds and sound
panels and cameras and all of these
other things in here but we want to use
the space use the things so that we can
communicate something that we want to
communicate in order to do that
i look at what is the sort of minimum
viable way to do that because i don't we
could have just kept the white walls and
no lighting no sound panels it would
have been echoey as hell
it wouldn't have worked right
and you and i aren't against things i
mean we're celebrating with suits on
right now how ridiculous is this right i
own one suit because uh beck's
occasionally uh has impromptu funerals
or something that she wants me to go to
she attends a lot of funerals man oh wow
people we don't know she just shows up
shows up it's really her passion don't
funeral crashers yeah
it's a sequel we're working on
but so yeah i own a suit right i used to
own a bunch of suits for the corporate
world even then i had too many suits
what was my why for re-cluttering my
closet then it was because oh one more
suit will finally make me complete i get
this even now you know i'm
my
my one blind spot are jackets i have
like six jackets at home yeah still
we live in los angeles california
and here's the thing they all fit within
all of my rules because i wear wear them
all the time and they fit in the 90 90
rule or whatever but could i have one
jacket and one coat maybe yeah probably
yeah but i do get value from each of
them yeah and
and so if i was hanging on to a bunch of
jackets that i wasn't wearing well then
they would be what they'd be clutter
yeah and so if you have a bunch of
things in your life that don't serve a
purpose they don't bring you joy in some
way that's what clutter is yeah there's
something about having options because
we were talking about this before we
were recording the show in the corporate
world i loved
having my allen edmonds
and uh you have a pair of shoes by the
way oh right yeah it's a nice pair like
a really really nice pair of uh like
leather shoes
um all types of styles i could wear a
different style you know every day for
you know two weeks in a row several
months right exactly yeah people go like
the you know how to do the shows on
youtube now the complex sneaker shopping
you show people's closets you could have
come to our closets there would have
been a bunch of allen edmonds shoes just
sort of stacked up in an absurd way i
don't know so i've got this pair of
allen edmonds on right now i still own
one pair of allen edmonds and i don't
know if you had the same thing but i own
several of the same pair of shoes oh
with the allen that like back in the
corporate days yes yes well there is
again there's something and maybe it is
conditioning it's society just you know
ruining our minds but having the options
is like
it's this little burst of ephemeral like
oh yeah i got plenty of options yeah but
it's like it's never enough
like with the jackets it's like you
could probably get one more jacket
find use out of it um yeah i mean it's
just it's never enough if i just had the
jacket from back to the future that
didn't have like self drying or air
conditioned or self drying yeah i just
need one jacket that we can do
everything that's actually the mindset
that goes into a lot of this right yeah
this is going to be the final purchase
and here's the irony here ryan is
minimalism actually helps me much more
with that than consumerism consumerism
is the ideology that buying something
will complete me or make me happy now
you and i obviously know and people
listening to this at home or on their
treadmill or driving to work or wherever
you are you know
intellectually that the thing isn't
going to make you happy what you don't
know if you're yearning for it is
viscerally you're like yeah but let me
try to find out right you know i might
be wrong about this intellectually my
heart knows best and my heart knows that
one more jacket will finally make me
complete
however
if
if we approach it from a minimalist
mindset a minimalist knows i'm already
complete
the stuff isn't going to make me more
complete in fact it's probably going to
get in my way
however some things
if i buy it i'm taking care it's taking
care of that decision essentially
forever permanently great example of
this
our friend frank who's in our first
documentary he's a minimalist architect
we have a few minimalist architects in
the building we work in as well greg and
christian downstairs and i've talked
i've had several conversations with them
about this
when a minimalist architect plans a home
they plan a home for the rest of the
person's life
you take care of that and even with
frank in our documentary the couch that
he bought he spent three years looking
for that couch
couldn't find it so he had it built
custom
and the reason he did that
he made a very deliberate decision once
this is decisions made i never have to
consider this
ever again
the problem is we take that mindset into
consumerism i'll just buy this real
quick and i'll never have to consider
this again in a month from now i'm like
why did i buy that thing it's too big
it's too small it's too long it's too
short whatever it is
it doesn't fit me
literally but also doesn't fit
me psychologically emotionally
and then i just pay the cost in so many
other ways as a result yeah man i gotta
pick the answer for you what is it the
stuff doesn't fill the emotional void
it widens it yeah i borrowed that from
ryan he said that in our last film les
is now on netflix and um
the stuff doesn't fill the void
in fact the void isn't real we did a
whole patreon episode about this with
jeanette mccurdy
called the void oh yeah the void
is something that has been created by
your programming by the construct spot
by society so has been created by you
but really by the programming that has
been installed in you by the people
around you you wouldn't experience that
same void had you been birthed and
raised on a deserted island by just your
mother and immediate family
that void does not exist in reality
uh i got a couple petty answers uh
my first one is mo possessions mo
puff
problems
i think it was biggie right i don't know
it was well it was a song they did
together okay yeah yeah and so uh what i
like about that i i love that answer i
think it's gonna work great as an image
or for the show notes whatever by the
way if you want our show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com
but mo possessions no problems because
it's not actually the the possessions
that are the problem it's me that's the
problem right it's my programming that's
the problem yeah but those possessions
are a result of that programming and so
it is still true because if i have more
because more and more and more and more
if i yearn for more and more and more
what does that do it shows it displays
it reveals
my programming yeah yeah no for sure the
other one i have is uh when in doubt go
without i think i've used that one
before i like it but
i mean that's really how i kind of look
at things it's if i'm questioning oh
should i shouldn't i if i can go without
it i just go without yes and i don't
ever you know look back and think oh man
i really i really should have got that
thing
i should have done that the wait the
wait for it rule yeah right exactly i've
really been wanting a pair of allen
edmonds
um
they're
they're very
beautiful shoes i don't know how else to
describe it i've been looking for a
reason
and but but that to me is a symptom of
like oh you need to go without that yeah
especially when i'm searching like when
can i wear them because i don't even
know when i would wear them right when
we celebrate
art galleries yes
art reveals we're gonna have to open
more art galleries just so you can wear
some allen edmonds right exactly well
here's the thing about that so i'll give
you three reasons to not get them
one is they're far less comfortable than
any other shoes that i have
they're comfortable for dress shoes
but they're dress shoes you're not gonna
go jogging them no and they're real
slippery too so there's another thing
for you're gonna fall in these i have i
broke a hip once uh at in bridgewater
falls and cincinnati ohio did you break
your hip yeah i don't remember that yeah
wow yeah well it was like my uh yeah
anyway anyway yeah it was a hairline
fracture i had it was a hilarious moment
i'm walking back to speak with jason
ratliff and uh
shout out yeah shout out to jason
ratliff and uh i'm walking with two cups
of coffee in my head from hand from
panera i think it was or the bookstore
borders blizzard
it was
it's winter in ohio i'm walking back to
his retail store i got you a coffee and
all of a sudden i hit a patch of black
ice in my allen edmonds
vertical i mean i went from vertical to
horizontal immediately oh my gosh in the
air
coffee's up in the air
i wish we had a slow-motion gif of this
because it would have been perfect
but i don't alas it was 2008
and uh yeah oh my god that hurt and uh
it was because of these shoes so there's
a good excuse they're slippery they're
uncomfortable what was the third one
well you're not uh you're never going to
wear them yeah right that's that's the
best
that's the best reason right there all
right
so therefore
they're not going to add value to your
life i wear these probably three four
times a year
and whenever i wear a suit i wear this
suit with this i have one dress shirt
like this and i have one blue tie one
black tie
and and that's it and um even then i
look at it and i'm like um i'm i'm still
constantly questioning does this still
add value to my life why because if it
doesn't
well then eventually
what was valuable is now clutter yeah
amen ryan we got a bunch more to talk
about you got something for us first
yeah man here are some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
check them out hey minimalists this is
christina calling from waterloo ontario
canada i just listened to your career
podcast and wanted to call to say how
much i loved it
i think it's so important to find what
you're passionate about and just go for
it kind of continue to cultivate that
passion and push through the low parts
i actually started writing a fashion
blog back in 2013 and it's continued to
grow from there
i studied to be a style coach and
launched my own side businesses past
november and now i work one-on-one with
people to develop their own personal
style
i've always been passionate about
promoting local shopping in my community
but i realized after listening to the
podcast that i'm going to focus even
more on teaching my clients on how to
shop according to their values
more eco-friendly and really help them
minimize their closets i just wanted to
thank you guys for helping me realize
this and for all you guys do
hi guys this is marley in cleveland
tennessee
and i'm a newbie to your podcast and
i've already hooked
maybe it's because you spoke about one
of my favorite subjects creativity
i want to share how liberating it is
that you give people permission
to practice failing
when i learn the wisdom that the brick
wall of frustration is the part of the
creation creative process
it set me free
once i knew that this was part of the
process
i could know where i was and go on to
the next steps of incubating my creative
idea
strategizing new ideas and collaborating
with others
so at that brick wall of frustration i
didn't quit and go home
but i kept at it seeing it through to
the success moments
also a tip on the have to versus the get
to in your creative process
one inquiry you could ask
is the eee test
does this have ease
not to be confused with easy because our
life's creativity isn't always easy
but does it flow with ease
does it have great energy
and do i enjoy it
that's when you know in your bones that
you are doing something you love
all right y'all we got a bunch more
surprise questions this thursday on
patreon that's the maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast but first
real quick for right here right now
here's one or maybe even two things
going on in the life of the minimalist
so i teach a writing class three or four
times a year i'm going to teach it one
more time this year we we changed we
recorded everything we brought jordan
and sean in and other sean shawn mahalik
who is an adjunct professor over there
at how to write better we reformatted
the entire class i'm going to teach it
one more time later this year it's
closed right now so you can't sign up
for it but if you're interested in
finding out more information you can
download the free ebook it's called 11
ways to write better even if you don't
not interested in the class whatsoever
you can download that ebook for free or
you'll walk away with at least 11
different ways to improve your writing
it's howtorightbetter.org
you can also find information about the
class over there as well as some
testimonials
howtowrightbetter.org for added value
this week ryan i thought it'd be
appropriate to talk about beulah heck
yeah so you can follow beulah she
created all this beautiful artwork she's
also doing the interior design for our
space do you know mike over at la sound
panels just hired her to create this
like zen garden area for him as well
awesome uh because he has got this these
recording trailers all these different
recording studios where people record
okay so she's going to design he loved
what she was doing with this space and
he was like oh yeah i could use someone
who just she has this amazing eye for
aesthetics you'll see it on her
instagram right away yeah but if you're
interested in beautiful art for your
home as well she has a website i know
she takes commissions and things like
that
goldmorning.com is her website and in
fact at some point when we switch out
some of this artwork some of this
in-studio artwork this actual artwork
will be for sale from her eventually but
right now you can just check out her all
of her beautiful art it's stunning
goldmorning.com now ryan i thought we
would end this episode we're gonna have
andrew bell on the podcast in a few
weeks can't wait his new album just came
out heck yeah and it is
i don't even know how to describe it man
it is
a dream on
vinyl i mean it is like it or on record
it's been a recorded dream it's just
stunning um and we're gonna have him in
to talk about the album but also just
talk about how do you
this is minimalist he's the new age
minimalist composer in a way and how his
music has evolved is unbelievable you
can see that yeah it's a great album
it's incredible and so let's finish this
episode with his new single from that
album by the way the album is called
nightshade
which
is a great title we're going to talk
about why it's a great title when he
comes on to the the podcast but this is
a song from that album it's called i'm
so excited for you by the way we have a
bunch more surprise questions this week
like how do we ensure we are using our
closets for their intended purpose
rather than as miniature storage units
if you have a monotonous job that
requires you to sit at a computer all
day what practices can you adopt to
avoid impulsively buying non-essentials
how do i keep my interior design fresh
and interesting without bringing in a
bunch of new items plus what are 25
things that joshua and ryan avoid for a
more intentional life and of course a
million more questions for the
minimalists and if you want to hear all
that join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week visit patreon.com the
minimalists to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll get access to all of our past
archives as well private archives public
archives ask the minimalist anything
sessions and our patreon community plus
recorded live events our past live
events and our upcoming live events are
available to patrons over there as well
patreon.com
the minimalist you can follow the
minimalist on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalist come to one
of our live podcast shows they're coming
up real soon the minimalists.com tour to
find all 20 cities near you and also
sign up for our email list over there
for future cities and if you sign up for
our email list you can also get our
podcast show notes in your inbox you can
comment on this episode on youtube
youtube.com the minimalist and if you
leave here today with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you
need every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it